en inde au milieu des bidonvilles de
calcutta capitale du bengale
jean paul ii est allé à la rencontre de
mère teresa prix nobel de la paix mais
aussi à la découverte de la misère la
plus absolue
le dénouement de milliers de femmes et
d'hommes recueillis par les religieuses
jean paul ii à calcutta
commentaire de philippe rochot jean paul
ii la calcutta c'est le message de
l'église à la pauvreté
pour la première fois un pape dans cette
capitale du bengale qui n'a jamais
réussi à faire vivre ces centaines de
milliers de réfugiés fuyant les guerres
de neige et les catastrophes naturelles
pour la première fois aussi un patch et
mère teresa
l'hommage rendu à l'oeuvre des
missionnaires de la charité dont
l'action a permis de sauver des milliers
de visuels et soulager les pauvres au
seuil de la mort c'est le plus beau jour
de ma vie a déclaré mr teresa à
l'intérieur du mouroir jean paul de
serre depuis longtemps si la d1000 deux
malades sur le point de mourir
il a aidé les missionnaires de la
charité à servir les repas
sa visite au mouroir installé dans un
temple de cali restera sans doute le
temps fort de son voyage en oeuvre
auparavant jean paul ii s'était arrêtée
le temps d'une messe dans la petite
ville de ranchi au coeur d'une région
tribale
malgré l'hostilité d'extrémistes hindous
gens comme yeux n'a pas hésité à
dénoncer le système des castes et en
inde qui réduit en esclavage les
millions derby donc